[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vie pour
aujourd'hui j'accueille un enfant de la
vallée mais gêné vous un enfant de la
vallée de chevreuse c'est michka assayas
bonjour mischka aujourd'hui merci d sur
notre plateau d'avoir accepté cette
invitation je suis très très contente de
vous voir en vrai oui bon c'est déjà vu
en vrai oui mais en vrai parce qu'en
fait on est habitué aux vous entendre
c'est un homme de radio cette annonce de
musique
on va essayer de vous découvrir un peu
plus parce que les gens que les autres
voient bien évidemment mais pas votre
tête donc ça y est ça c'est fait enfin
merci d'être passé
donc vous êtes un enfant la vallée de
chevreuse vous avez plusieurs casquettes
leur corde à votre arc en dit vous êtes
auteur vous êtes journaliste vous êtes
producteur d'une émission de radio qui
s'appelle very good trip depuis 2015 sur
france 5 ans déjà 5 ans et vous êtes
tous les je le dis maintenant parce que
comme ça on est sûr de l'avoir dit ah
d'accord
donc c'est à 21h jusqu'à 22h du lundi au
jeudi sur france inter
et tout à l'heure on parlera de l'été
par le jeu de sa course passée aussi des
choses cet effet chez vous voilà alors
on va déjà revenir à vous comment vous
avez fait l'école normale supérieure ens
dieu
je les fait enfin oui et non c'est à
dire une logique et j'ai passé le
concours
à l'époque c'était les garçons
saint-cloud visiter le concours dit
moderne mais en fait j'ai pris la fuite
je voulais pas enseigné à l'époque on
est on traitait pas que ça vienne jeune
normalien on les embête house noc et il
cédé très difficile de devenir insistant
tout ça donc je suis là là je vais être
prof d'être aigri je vais être
malheureux puis j'ai été passionné par
ce qui se passait dans la musique à
l'époque donc c'était plus excitants de
d'aller interviewer des groupes 1 à
londres donc direct vous êtes oui oui
dans le journal y oui ils ont été
interviewés rock et folk libération elle
avait aussi écrit pour les
inrockuptibles il a plus tard oui oui
j'étais déjà super ça y est je vous
savez je suis très belle frayeur
question fait oui j'ai connu c'était des
gamins en fait moi j'étais déjà un vieux
à l'époque un petit peu plus oui oui
voilà j'étais un jeu faisait figure de
celui qui avait référent voilà deux ans
figure tutélaire c'est donc tout ça
journaliste katie drogue vous avez aussi
écrit plusieurs romans une avait écrit
le fameux dictionnaire du rock doui une
sensible à tout seul bref oui même été
réédité en 2004 où tout voilà donc donc
référence en la matière et après vous
avez donc rejoint le monde de la radio
oui enfin c'était moi on m'a téléphoné
j'avais déjà fait une chronique autant
de
bernard lenoir les années 90 mais enfin
je lisais un papier j'étais très j'étais
tétanisée j'avais une voix blanche tout
ça je me sentais pas du tout capable de
faire de la radio et déjà vous aimiez le
principe j'étais très lent je n'aimais
pas trop enfin je veux dire que c'était
j'avais une sorte de fébrilité
j'étais très excité d'être là je me
sentais mais je me sentais pas tout à
fait à ma place pas très légitimes a
mobilisé un papier quoi oui oui pardon
j'avais pas fait sous traiter en inde et
donc et puis on m'a téléphoné c'était
quelqu'un qui travaillait qui est
d'avoir des programmes de france inter
dès noël manuel perreault qui m'a
demandé si ça m'intéressait sur une
série d'été c'est en 2015 et j'ai dit
oui
et merci oui puis avant we dance music
j'avais oublié enfin les france musique
un peu ça a été très nouveau pour moi
c'était marc voinchet qui m'avait
demandé et je me suis pris au jeu ça a
plutôt bien marché mais là je me sens
beaucoup plus dans mon élément
depuis quelques années je avec very good
oui vraiment est ce que c'est un domaine
qui vous est propre que vous connaissez
le oui parce que c'est un peu la
synthèse de tout ce que j'ai fait ces
terres dans le sens où je j'avais
toujours l'impression que m'intéresser
au rock il ya 40 30 ans c'était quand
même un truc très marginale de sarcelles
voilà c'est ça c'était pas très bien
sérieux et puis parallèlement genre de
mandater des jets qui fait de la
critique littéraire aussi j'écris dvd
calero moment et c'est déjà un succès
c'était noble cause était sérieux et
puis là au foot les deux choses se sont
rejoints tout dit d'ailleurs ces deux
mondes différents
oui la littérature et la musique est là
enfin bernard j'écris mes émissions des
leçons des récits mais ce sont des
récits et le côté littéraire qui me
caractérise s'exprime dans mon approche
parce que je serais incapable de faire
ce que je fais si je préparais pas si je
me documentais pas si je ne tournais pas
mes phrases plusieurs fois et c'est
enfin bon je travaille vite c'est sûr
parce qu'une quotidienne on peut pas
réécrire dix fois mais enfin néanmoins
je je m'efforce de de faire comme si ça
allait être publié
voilà d'accord oui ça a été ça va
essayer plusieurs s'est il écrit oral
voilà c'est ça mais vous dis donc avec
vous écrivait comme vous parlez oui
c'est ça mais c'est une manière de trous
donc c'est une sorte de compromis entre
la spontanéité de la conversation et
la rigueur et l'exactitude de l'écrit
parce que d'ailleurs c'est jean lebrun
qui avait été le maître de marc voinchet
qui a dit à qui m'a dit que la radio
était un genre écrit d'accord oui
bonjour la spontanéité bah vous entendez
ça s'entend beaucoup maintenant un mois
j'essaie quand même de faire quelque
chose qu'ils ramenaient leur spontanéité
n'est plus dans la vie voilà merci alors
le pire de votre émission hausse est
donné envie s'imagine de faire découvrir
alors ce qu'on me dit est ce que je
partage c'est que quelle que soit
finalement le type de musique que vous
abordez que ce soit le jazz la soul le
reggae blues le rock et vous arrivez à
donner envie à quelqu'un qui n'aime pas
ce style de musique est mon idée d'aller
d'aller écouter ou est ce que vous
proposez parce que si vous voulez si je
mens tenait à ce que son mégot les plus
intimes
bon au goût du jour une réponse
démission ou peut-être deux mois or
comme j'ai fait une encyclopédie que je
me suis un peu obligé à m'intéresser à
des styles de musique peut-être j'avais
survolé ou que je méprise est odieux
donc j'ai plus besoin de m'identifier à
groupe un chanteur en disant voilà c'est
vraiment où ils représentent médias les
noms abbaoui babonneau incident avait
écrit un livre d'entretiens oui oui bono
j'ai juste dit c'est ça c'est le côté
les rip issa qaraqe c'est rare de
j'étais copain avec lui quand personne
ne le connaissait ça c'est comme avoir
été à l'école avec le pape sy ses fruits
cette fois mais je sais qu'ils vous
jamais été à l'école avec le pape et
d'autres
et pardon je vous ai coupé c'est
intelligent donc voila vous intéresser à
d'autres styles de musique oui voilà
j'avais découvre moi même je me hâte un
jeu mais finalement ça s'est même si
j'aime pas écouter du reggae tous les
jours ça je peux aussi sam touche - je
pense que ça pourra toucher tout le
monde et donc j'essaye de transmettre
mon
ma découverte est oui oui voilà parfois
j'ai parfois je ne m'oblige à écouter
des trucs que j'écouterais pas spontanée
monsieur mais je je m'intéresse à tous
en réalité voilà c'est la curiosité
accueillis dans les songes et des 1 26
ans il ya des choses extrêmes qui aurait
pas que j'écouterais ça chez moi tous
les jours dans ma voiture mais je suis
curieux quoi vous savez je suis comme
quelqu'un qui va dans un dans un pays
dans une ville étrangère et qui essayait
d'ouvrir toutes les portes
voilà sans frapper sans frais en
revanche vous êtes curieux vous aimez
transmettre si oui voilà jacques
important qui est alors cet été qu'est
ce qu'on va alors ces tests l'eba dans
la drague et puis voilà et bien il y
aura une série de neuf émission d'été
sur bob marley voilà donc je vais parler
de bob marley avant que le monde entier
le connaissent quand il faisait des
voilà seulement quand il était connu
dans se rendre sur son île la jamaïque
avec les wailers
j'ai dû faire plein de trésors plein de
trucs vraiment que seuls les érudits les
spécialistes connaissent et qu'ils sont
vraiment assez extraordinaire et pitt
voilà la strack enfin dos alors ça sera
le samedi à partir de samedi prochain 27
juin à 16 heures et le dimanche à 10
heures
jusqu'il ya du matin 10h du matin bien
de la messe voilà c'est un peu ça
pendant les jo
écoutez c'est bien pour l'été un oui ça
va oui se dandiner lascivement sur voilà
c'est le programme est alors moi j'ai lu
oui j'ai vu plusieurs livres mais là
celui-là que j'adore le premier qui
s'appelle les années vide
oui mon pauvre vous parlez d'une espèce
de choc et je me demande si c'est pas de
là qu'est venu si je retrouve mon truc
les pets sens oui oui oui louis dubreil
oui ça m'a disons que je ne sais pas
vous savez il ya un jour c'est une voix
qui vous parviennent à ces dieux oui bah
moi c'était en effet la voix des deux
groupes de deux jeunes californiens qui
avait eu cette image un peu de crétins
joyeux qui faisait du surf est en fait
gg j'ai ressenti une sorte de voix
intérieure je sais pas comment dire
quelqu'un qui m'a qui m'a comme manama
sur les plans est ce que tu dis c'est
pas si grave
la musique va t'aider et peut-être avait
aidé à s'en sortir parce que j'allais
pas très bien j'étais bon voilà j'étais
un peu nous c'était oui c'était pas gay
s'était pas gaessler qu'en fait que
cette idée que la joie de l'enfance un
jour où vous savez moi j'étais un enfant
très joyeux et puis un jour ça s'arrête
et on comprend pas pourquoi il surtout
que j'ai une expérience que je raconte
d'ailleurs dans les années vivent de
dépucelage assez assez violente
on parle beaucoup de nuages écrit un
texte là dessus du consentement oui on
parle beaucoup de mythes ou et enfin
comme si comme si en fait vraiment
toutes les femmes étaient des pauvres
créatures innocente et tous les hommes
étaient des vicelard prédateurs et j'ai
raconté que c'était plus
c'était bon c'était pas toujours vrai
avec le contraire soit le contraire et
que un homme qui est sous l'emprise d'un
enfant je pense que je devrais
charismatique mais on sait pas trop
comment se défendre c'est pas parce
qu'on bande et que celui qui pénètre que
en effet un violeur prédateur parti
c'est plus c'est plus trouble c'est plus
trouble oui surtout que j'étais un peu
sous l'emprise voilà j'étais sous une
emprise venant prise de recul hier et
alors alors moi ce qui m'a fait rire on
finira mais vous parlez alors je dis pas
qu'ils les essayent 2
elle avait des fesses énorme boudinée
dans des pantalons synthétique et
portait des coiffure bouffante qui
ressemblait à de petites montgolfières
noir mais avec 7 à l'époque ça claque
comme la naissance des images qui le
classe qui se massent les gens grêle
l'afrique et tout un tas de bons c'est à
lire à défaut de voilà donc on va vous
écoutez donc là c'est terminé votre c
reconduit pour l'année prochaine au
malawi écouter chanter we rejet qui le
dit mot consent comme on dit non non
mais oui il y assure normalement oui
voilà on a coûté ça serait trop triste
et voilà et puis donc on vous écoute cet
été avec bob marley louis votre nouvel
âge les écrivains sinon ça va venir vite
et vous l'avez dit oui je travaille vite
m'enfin là c'est un peu angoissant
zut oui bon bah écoutez moi je crois en
vous et vous voilà j'ai pas la seule et
un grand merci en tout cas dans le
résultat
marlène venir nous voir c'est pas là où
vous êtes en voisins les yvelines c'est
une petite région
voilà la grotte et à très vite sur les
ondes invite enfin
[Musique]